and man powers yet I um the crap ant-man
so ant-man's the newest movie in the
hold on yeah there we go so it means the
new movie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe starring Paul Rudd Paul Rudd
play Scott he just gets out of jail he
did some time because he stole some
stuff but he's not like a bad guy he's
not just some scumbag criminal he's a
guy who did a thing then the original
ant-man Hank Pym played by Michael
Douglas in the most brilliant way
possible wants to recruit him to take
the mantle of the ant-man because he
needs him to break into a place and
steal some because if he doesn't
bad things are gonna go down because of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe bad shits
always happening at this born I was
hopeful yet skeptical about this movie
Edgar Wright was originally doing it you
saw his concept footage and Comic Con
that one year and you were like oh my
god that looks awesome
Edgar Wright walks and you're like why
he find out it's because they wanted to
tie it into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and I guess you didn't want to
do that or something like that so you
start getting worried you're like oh god
I just got a shoe horn references the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in this movie
that would probably just be fine on its
own now it worked out very well because
I had a great time with this movie I
liked the characters it was exciting the
action was great the premise as absurd
as it is was executed so well it's as
good as an ant-man movie was ever going
to be like I already said Paul Rudd he
was great in the movie he was believable
he was likable you're rooting for him
and you know Paul Rudd wants it because
he's Paul Rudd and if Paul Rudd is
approaches like hey you want to be in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as the
star of a Marvel movie you know he's
gonna be like hell yeah and I'm gonna
put all I got into that Michael Douglas
as Hank Pym man I haven't seen a lot of
Michael Douglas lately so you see him in
a Marvel movie you're like alright
maybes cuz they got him on a budget I
don't know I hope to god he was the
highest-paid actor in this movie cuz
holy he is so great as Hank Pym I
honestly want to see a prequel movie
where Hank Pimm's in his prime played by
Michael Douglas somehow she owned his
age at this point it doesn't look quite
as young as he did when he was nailing
Sharon Stone I would just like to see a
Hank Pym prequel movie I gotta say the
scale of this movie is toned down you're
coming fresh off an age of Ultron man
you just saw a robot try to destroy the
human race and now we have Ant Man which
is a heist movie where someone needs to
break into a place and steal something
but I love heist movie
seriously I do so you have this heist
movie they keep it in the pocket they
have some Marvel Cinematic Universe
references you got a really cool power
that they use well at comic-con footage
we saw where ant-man is running down the
hallway and he turned small runs up the
gun and around the tie and turns big and
flips the guy around that's the stuff I
wanted to see in this movie during the
action sequences and the fights ant-man
is turning small he's turning big he's
doing everything he can to work the
momentum around you just kick some solid
ass and I thought yellowjacket was a
really badass villain but with the
action sequences it made for really good
action sequences that first shot you see
you see it in the trailer to where the
camera kind of looks up at me like
stands up and you see you late cannons
whatever that is even out behind
him is you know gear into place I love
that shot I saw that in trailer I was
like that dude looks like he's gonna own
some face you see in the movie
your life as shot is still awesome but
his character is pretty like cliche
villain not only that it looks like
ant-man took some notes from iron man's
playbook seriously an Iron Man someone
makes this remarkable piece attack
there's some scumbag who works in the
company duplicates the tech and then
those two pieces is attacked need to
fight ant-man is pretty much the same
thing with ice-t-- in there but if it
works to introduce Iron Man and the
entire Marvel Cinematic Universe to the
world bet your ass it works to introduce
ant-man to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and the first 15 maybe 20 minutes of
this movie was a little bumpy the intro
scene great and then after the titles
come on there wasn't as much flow it's
like they wanted to show you so much
information just chop it up to feed it
to you so you get right to the ant-man
stuff not a huge complaint especially
since you forget about it by the end of
the movie but still worth addressing
because it is a review after all guys in
the end I really loved ant-man it was
hilarious the action was great the
relationship between Hank Pym and his
daughter it's great you kind of see how
Hank Pym sees Scott is kind of this son
he never had kind of thing the
references and tie-ins they have in
ant-man to the Cinematic Universe
completely works so organically just
slides the movie right in there like a
missing piece to a puzzle and you just
you welcome it I walked out of this
movie liking it far more than I thought
I could possibly like ant-man
and I will say ant-man is most certainly
worth buying on blu-ray it's good to see
that Marvel knows they don't need to
make the next movie bigger than the last
I hope they know that going forward I
feel like if you really about
ant-man you're bitching about it because
at this point you've seen a lot of
Marvel movies you're just kind of sick
of the whole thing okay to each his own
I'm just not there yet alright so
ant-man have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more